I really feel like I need this I need to
start this video with a schauder to mow
tatum AKA ex-mo tatum aka the dino pack
guy who's made the Dino pack in politics
which is one of the first things i'll
play around with in this episode it's
got some amazing stuff and a fanboy over
it way too much but it's got some phones
crunch robbery some small fences which
also kind of like and palm trees which
are all of the things that we needed in
park sex but we're missing so far but
now we now have which is really cool I
also really need to express my utmost
gratitude about the system of how you
make observation towers and launched
hours in this game because they are so
amazing literally you you build the ride
and then it just looks like a short
stump that is just completely ugly but
you can actually just grab the top and
just hover your mouse up and down and
the length of the tower will follow with
some amazing sounds playing during doing
that sweet Kelly really cool and I sort
of liked it actually there was a video
where the codemaster was playing this
game and he was like stuck for a couple
of minutes just dragging a launch tower
up and down I need to drop tower
whatever same thing which was actually
exactly how I feel about that function
is well off-camera I've actually spent a
lot of time doing that stuff it's it I
don't know why but it's actually sort of
fun to do and that's pretty much that
there is magically foliage has appeared
around the pirate ship ride and this
episode will be mostly not about this
little food court which is more of a
snack bar inspired little thing but it's
mostly about something which I wanted to
try somewhere in the corner of this park
which is honestly sort of does sort of
reveal the entire idea of this park
which is mostly to figure out stuff in
panic attacks and see what you can
really do in it but I'm gonna create a
large well pretty big hill really it's
so large that it should probably be a
natural hill which means that this park
is not an another lens bundle not sure
about that where I want to have a log
flume of course and I wanted to get a
Mine Train I
and I literally felt so stupid about
that I was playing the game I was like
right I'm gonna add a mind train around
there and that was like my thought for
20 minutes playing this game and for the
longest time I was looking for the mine
train I thought I couldn't remember
where it was but then I remembered that
the skin doesn't have a mind train so
it's gonna be here with the log flume
and a suspended coaster which is very
Six Flags ish which it 100% is it's
gonna be a big ripoff of Ninja and
that's pretty much what's gonna happen
in here but not yet because I still
needed to do some foliage over here and
actually finish the path that leads up
to the pirate ship and which is right
behind the pirate ship is where I do
wanna have that big mountain where the
log flume should have about two drops
and where hopefully a suspended coaster
will be happily swinging over the log
flume and over the lake and around and
well pretty much through with the
mountain at least that was the idea it
turned how to become a lot harder than I
was hoping but in the end I do think it
works out all rights so you'll see that
shortly I think and in the meantime this
little area over here with the pirate
ship ride still sort of needs to be
finished what I was a bit unsure about
the queue line especially since I wanted
to have one of these little you know
sandy paths that you very often have
that go to these well swing shifts but
any tropical ride really kind of diving
through the foliage and rock work here
and there but really the choice of parts
at the moment it's way too limited to
even try something like that so that's
basically the idea behind the weird
sudden yellow path leading from the
swinging ship which I'll be doing more
it sort of represents a sandy part it
probably doesn't look like it and it
probably looks like [ __ ] but that's the
idea behind it and the idea behind this
little observation thing is I just want
a place from which you could look at the
pirate ship and other than that it's
completely ripped off from the pirate
ship and uses the same color scheme and
these same wooden things because I could
really come up with anything else and I
figured I could just get it in the same
style and that would be all nice and
dandy so that's why that's there and
that's pretty much it for this area I
think not that there's really anything
else I'm at this point when I was still
doing this I sort of wanted to continue
beyond the carousel over there and see
what I wanted to do with that but really
I was way too unsure so just kind of did
some side stuff like added little burns
inside the planters and things like that
which is pretty much why did in the next
20 minutes because that's essentially
what i felt like park tech was missing
still ways without the mods is and this
is gonna sound like a big roller coaster
can three circle jerk but its ground
shrubbery for anyone who doesn't know
about that entire roller coaster in
three circle jerk is that i don't know
for how many years but pretty much for
as long as i can remember has been a
sort of running gag around ground
shrubbery whereas people would complain
about other people's rides and give
harsh criticism saying that it didn't
have enough ground shrubbery and it only
has enough ground Shawbury when you
can't see the ground that's pretty much
it there is no such thing as too much
ground shrubbery and that is why there
are so many shrub cuz some scenery sets
in roller coaster in three and why you
find so many kosas in wallach oh sick
and three that were made by people that
have way too much stuff going on on the
ground which sort of turned into one big
joke but I open up architect and it
doesn't even have any bushes whatsoever
so having those little ferns and as
little plants from the dino pack as
small the changes it does seem it does
really help to have some ground
shrubbery which is almost necessary
really I don't think even rollercoaster
tycoon one had it really but it's it's
something that makes your ground look a
lot better if you're in 3d view and
rather than isometric since the ground
is quite boring and grass is boring and
having some interesting ferns and lots
of flowers to look at at the ground
however unrealistic it may be always
sort of just looks a little bit more
attractive than having completely empty
gross which is sort of
why I went to spam crunch rubbery from
the data back in this park as well so
that's the entire story behind that I
suppose this little opening over here
where it opens up quite a large lake was
pretty much necessary to get the log
flume going and the log flume will sort
of well actually you'll see that in a
bit but I was planning to just build the
mountain first see what ever it would
look like eventually and then only after
the mountain is finished get the log
flume inn and after that the coast
through so it was really if this
mountain failed and the log flume would
have filled and the input would have
been even worse and if this log flume
feels then it's going to be hard to
actually get an invert in around that
especially with it with our hit boxes so
it was kind of important to at least
have some sort of planning of what I
wanted to do so the big lake is where
this little log flume you should splash
down eventually and it sort of just kind
of makes it this way around the top of
the mountain but doesn't entirely make
it and I just felt like I really had to
make that little tunnel in order to
leave at least some space for the year
suspended coaster which in the end
probably wasn't enough space because i
still had major issues trying to fit the
suspended coaster in next to this log
flume but it's not too bad in the end I
hope it's not too bad really it'll all
be fine eventually as much over mess as
this mountain currently looks like it's
gonna be fine eventually hopefully that
was pretty much why I wanted to sit
through this entire thing anyway and
this little flat area is where I wanted
to have a restaurant which at first I
sort of wanted to make into a very
special restaurant but in the end it
turned into something else which we'll
see eventually in the next episodes but
yeah this is the basic layout of the log
flume is very short since I was very
much afraid that if I made the log flume
a lot larger and run around the mountain
a lot more I would have issues with the
suspended coaster which again I ran into
anyway but I suppose they aren't quite
as large at the moment as they could
have been if I made that log flume even
larger it is as much of a Magic Mountain
inspiration that this mountain is with
its suspended coaster and the log flume
it's certainly not as large as a magic
mountain and certainly not as much space
to play around with which made it quite
hard to actually fit this suspended
culture in which is why it actually
takes a couple of tries to get both the
station and the left hill and pretty
much all of the elements of this ride in
and yeah that was actually you just saw
that little piece of the lift Hill
become red and I still have no idea what
causes that but sometimes when you just
give a little certain length it turns
red and it doesn't work but then when
you slightly change the length of the
pieces before that point which you can't
place it suddenly places the exact same
piece fine I have no idea what's
actually going on with that it's a bit
annoying kind of like how this game
already forms tunnels if you're just a
little bit too close to the terraforming
I mean it's not too great of a solution
I suppose for hitting the ground with a
coaster car it's certainly not as bad as
well kosek in three words were just
completely demolish your entire mountain
if you only touched it a little bit with
your coaster but it's a it's a bit hard
to get this thing in also have it sort
of follow the ground a little bit while
knots creating tunnels and not hitting
the log flume which is why it actually
took a fair amount of time to get this
inverted coaster rides which I it's
pretty damn painful to look at it's
pretty damn painful to look at myself
just having so much trouble with trying
to get this with this suspended coasters
actually work but in the end I am quite
happy about it but you'll have to see
that in the next episode because this is
where I'm gonna cut this episode pretty
soon some evil like that haha so it just
kind of dips over the water over there
can I think it does a different dip
doesn't it yeah eventually it does a
different dip but you'll have to see
that in the next episode because it's
ending right here so see you then and
and thanks for watching of course I mean
and as always thanks for watching